this is from the 2004 HS ooh Mike plays
this game and he's got different
potential wins or losses and different
probabilities for each of them okay now
what this is kind of like is what we
looked at before we say rolling a die
and each of the options has a
probability and each of the options has
a value one through six in the cases of
a die here are the options for the
values and here are the options for the
probabilities so you might recall that
we said there was this thing called
expected value we said there was equal
to and then I introduced this weird
Greek letter
do you remember I introduced the Sigma
it's the Greek letter S and it just
means sum add up all the s um not not
some as in some of them it just means
sum so everything you're about to see
over here I want you to add up a whole
bunch of things what were the things we
added up there's the two pieces in this
okay very what's the P stand for
probability of the outcome or event yep
and we outcome an event sit on this
we're okay with that but I think this is
what I used very good
okay now financial expectation all that
means is well often the event that we're
talking about is a financial event
you're going to win some money or you're
going to lose some money or something
like that and you can see this question
is exactly set up to help us do evaluate
this thing over here okay so you're
going to need your calculator in a
second but what we're going to put into
that is for here Mike's financial
expectation it's going to be equal to
and I'm going to add up probability x
value probability x value until I've
done all of the possible events until
I've covered the entire sample size
what did I just do Oh today yeah I did
order it actually is it coming is it on
this way is that what it said oh no
that's my wife
a that burn got it
let's let's turn off the internet okay
this is not so bad in my year 10 class
in my year 10 class I've got everything
on and then they just like the Bluetooth
day I'm air drop things to me like and
I'm like guys and it's just like space
sloth what's this into a picture I'm
okay look good anyhow I I deserve that
where was I well you can't do it anymore
I just end up my wife I okay thank you
so I'm going to look at my three things
and I'm going to multiply each one
across but watch what happens first
there's a one-tenth chance of winning
$20 so that's your grand prize so
there's the probability of an event
value of her then that's the first part
I might pop that in brackets I'm going
to have the next one there's the
probability of this event this is quite
likely it's the most likely of all of
the outcomes 1/2 times $1 there's value
here comes the last one the probability
is 2/5 now just watch out here the value
of this last thing is not $2 it's losing
$2 so if we have numbers for this we
would say these are negatives so this is
actually multiplied by a negative $2 so
the financial expectation baked into it
yes there is a chance that you'll lose
out of this game right okay so you have
a calculator there let me see if I can
beat you there that's two dollars that's
50 cents and this two fifths of two
dollars is 80 cents a t-shirts right so
that's negative a sense two dolls 50
take away 80 cents that's going to be a
dollar 70s at one of the options for a
first one okay so what does this mean
what is this mean if for example Mike
played this game ten times right
sometimes he's going to win big some
time
he's going to win little sometimes he's
going to lose but each time on average
he should expect to gain a dollar 70 so
if you played 10 games then by the end
she might have you know 17 dollars or
something around that does that make
sense
so that's what he is expecting
financially to get out of this game so
that's not too complicated an idea it's
just a money version of this okay